lité françois poule et mathis
journalistes et spécialistes des
institutions européennes et frédéric
viale spécialiste des questions
européennes et auteur de la gauche à
l'épreuve de l'union européenne aux
éditions du croquant
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous alors cette question pour commencer
on viendra entendre les propos de michel
barnier françois poulet mathis et ce
qu'ils vous ont choqué et pourquoi
je veux dire que oui effectivement c'est
une véritable surprise parce qu'on
attendait pas du tout michel barnier sur
ce terrain michel barnier a toujours été
au sein de la famille gaulliste un de
ceux qui a toujours défendu une thèse
européenne vigoureuse et il a été
remarquablement appuyé lors de son
expérience de commissaire européen et
puis pendant toute son expérience où il
a été le négociateur du bric site et
michel barnier passe chez les gaullistes
et chez les eurosceptiques pour
quelqu'un qui défend l'europe à tout
prix or cette déclaration c'est un petit
peu une déclaration qui vient en
contradiction avec tout ce qu'il a été
avait même tout ce qu'il a défendu
pendant les négociations avec les
britanniques sur le break site qui en
essayant de persuader les britanniques
qu'il fallait à qu'ils acceptent se
soumettre aux arrêts de la cour de
justice de luxembourg qu'ils acceptent
la primauté du droit européen sur le
droit national ce que les britanniques
ce n'est pas prêt à accepter
or voilà que lui-même réclame une
souveraineté juridique c'est
effectivement un pavé dans la mare qui
met tout le monde un petit peu à court
parce que dans cette histoire ce qui est
dramatique c'est le manque de clarté
quand on défend une thèse on défend par
exemple un test selon lesquelles
l'europe est trop présente donc il faut
soit en sortir soit alors restreindre
son influence sur la vie courante des
européens c'est clair le message est
clair on n'en parle plus soit non on dit
il faut développer l'europe il faut la
renforcer
message par exemple qui est défendu par
l'actuel président de la république
emmanuel macron mais lorsque dans un
camp après avoir été aux rampes et 1 on
est en contradiction avec ses propres
yeux viola on sème le trouble on sème le
trouble est véritablement je crois que
michel barnier à semer un trouble je
suis pas sûr je ne suis pas du tout sûr
qu'ils en tirent un bénéfice électoral
dans la perspective des élections
présidentielles frédéric viale votre
avis votre réaction à ces propos de
michel barnier vous en avez pensé quoi
je pense que michel barnier n'est
absolument pas crédible lorsqu'il parle
de recouvrir la souveraineté juridique
parce que comme ça vient d'être dit et
là dessus je suis en parfait accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit il n'a à aucun
moment de sa carrière montré qu'ils
voulaient cette souveraineté juridique
il a été commissaire européen et c'est
un des robes et à l'est plus les plus
forcenés de ces dernières années donc en
fait on sent bien qu'on est dans une
période de crue maire à droite et ce
genre de propos ce sont des propos
électoralistes qui n'ont strictement
aucune portée voyez vous je trouve que
ce que peut proposer quelqu'un comme
montebourg qui porte un certain nombre
de choses sur des propositions concrètes
réalistes sur le recouvrement de la
souveraineté juridique là c'est beaucoup
plus crédible que ce que peut raconter
bernier quelles conséquences on vous
commencez à l'évoquer tout à l'heure
françois pour les mathis quelles
conséquences cela peut-il avoir sur sa
candidature à la primaire de la droite
je pense que la candidature va bien sûr
la maintenir il va essayer de la
renforcer il a un avantage à droite
michel barnier c'est que contrairement à
xavier bertrand et contrairement à
valérie pécresse qui se sont lancés dans
la bataille et qui sont très marqués
politiquement dans le camp politique
français michel barnier avait cette
image d'une certaine forme de pureté
d'indépendance qui finalement risques et
d'arranger tout le monde et ces
dernières semaines il a obtenu des
soutiens assez important de la part des
membres de son propre camp qui sont dits
plutôt que de choisir l'un des deux qui
se met en avant c'est à dire valérie
pécresse et xavier bertrand et bien
michel barnier peut-être peut-être notre
candidat idéal et donc il s'est senti un
peu mise en confiance dans cette optique
là dans cette dynamique là notamment aux
journées parlementaires de nîmes et bien
c'est peut-être ça qui l'entraînait
affaire la gaffe qu'il ne fallait pas
faire c'est à dire effectivement de
montrer qu'il est peut-être lui aussi un
peu fragile sur l'europe et donc c'est
en ça que je confirme un petit peu mon
impression c'est je suis pas sûr du tout
que cette déclaration d'avril essayer de
revenir en arrière pour dire oui mais ça
ne concernera que l'immigration mais le
problème c'est que l'immigration est
géré à la fois par les états nationaux
bien sûr mais gérer aussi par l'europe
dès le moment il faut harmoniser le
droit d'asile par exemple où il faut
organiser l'accueil des réfugiés et puis
c'est aussi organisées par les textes du
conseil de l'europe c'est-à-dire la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qui est gérée par la cour
internationale cour européenne de
justice de strasbourg sur ces deux
textes là il fragilise la position
finalement de la france où sa position
personnelle et donc là il faudra voir
effectivement peut-être dans les
sondages prochain si effectivement il
est en capacité de rester un petit peu
cet homme qui pourrait être le troisième
homme de l'élection présidentielle que
finalement il ne semble plus être ce
soir frédéric viale est ce que vous
pensez également que ça ça va lui porter
préjudice pour sa candidature à la
primaire va la droite
je pense réellement que la déclaration
de bernier est typiquement ce qu'on
appelle un non événement c'est à dire ce
sont des paroles en l'air qui l'a dit
parce que il se trouve placé devant
cette situation de les dire ou pour
essayer de gagner à droite sur la
question de l'immigration mais ce qui
est intéressant de commenter concernant
ce que raconte quelqu'un comme bernier
qui finalement n'a strictement aucune
importance puisqu'il n'ira pas très loin
c'est le fait que il croit dire pouvoir
dire ça parce que dans l'opinion il y a
effectivement quelque chose d'
extrêmement puissant qui ait la
nécessité pour la france de recouvrer sa
souveraineté on le voit
les différentes crises que nous avons
traversées ans et que nous continuons de
traverser l'union européenne aujourd'hui
globalement et même dans le camp de
bernier n'est plus perçu comme étant
l'alpha et l'oméga n'est plus perçu
comme étant la solution au problème mais
comme faisant partie des problèmes et
c'est ça qui est intéressant
politiquement c'est de voir
qu'aujourd'hui la notion de recouvrer la
souveraineté est une notion absolument
crucial est absolument crucial parce que
en effet nous en avons nous en avons
besoin nous ne pouvons plus continuer
avec cette union européenne telle
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire une union
européenne qui marque dans les traités
dans le marbre des traités des
politiques néolibérales qui sont aussi
bien
injuste socialement que désastreux
économiquement françois poulet mathis
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça la
souveraineté de toute façon un enjeu
pour tous pour tous les candidats à la
course à la présidentielle c'est un
c'est un thème important de nos jours en
france en tout cas il est tout il est
tout à fait exact je suis d'accord il ya
une
adhésion à l'idée qu'il faudrait
recouvrir une part de la souveraineté
perdue et que l'europe peut être en fait
trop tout simplement parce que les
européens n'ont peut-être pas été
suffisamment informés pendant toutes ces
années où les gouvernements ont pris des
initiatives font mettre en commun des
politiques et mettant en commun des
politiques mettant en commun de
nouvelles législations de nouvelles
règles qui font qu'actuellement il faut
être réaliste actuellement 60 à 70% de
notre vie quotidienne et soul influence
de la réglementation européenne et
peut-être que les européennes n'ont pas
été suffisamment conscients de cette
réalité est aujourd'hui effectivement il
ya une espèce de grande méfiance qui
tout à fait une victime qu'on peut
comprendre tout ce qui est tout à fait
respectable et qui nécessiteraient
peut-être que l'ensemble des vingt-sept
réfléchissent à une manière donc pas de
revenir en arrière mais peut-être
d'expliquer pourquoi finalement on a
fait tout ce travail en commun récupérer
de la souveraineté on peut pas par
récupérer une partie de la swat et ça ce
n'est pas possible on peut pas récupérer
une partie de nos règles communes et
puis laissez les autres ensembles ça
n'est pas possible l'europe est un tout
c'est une communauté de valeurs et c'est
surtout une communauté de droit dès le
moment où c'est une communauté de droit
eh bien ça veut dire qu'il y a des
règles communes qu'il faut respecter les
anglais l'ont compris et finalement ils
ont compris que dès le moment où ils en
sortaient belle ne faisait pas partie de
l'ensemble il pouvait à ce moment là
effectivement s'en affranchir dès le
moment où on est dedans il faut choisir
et il faut en tirer les conclusions cela
dit les gouvernements devraient faire
davantage de travail d'efforts de
pédagogie pour expliquer comment
finalement cette législation arrive
j'ajouterai une chose à propos du
libéralisme de l'europe qui est un petit
peu là la foire d'empoigné sur lequel
les opinions se
se cristallisent ce libéralisme il est
dû simplement à la réalité politique des
pays qui composent l'europe lorsqu'une
majorité de pays sont des pays à
dominante libéral effectivement il ya
une tendance à ce que l'europe elle-même
épouse cette forme de libéralisme
lorsque par exemple mittelland était
tout voir en france schneider en
allemagne y avait de véritables
possibilités d'une action sociale plus
importante donc je crois que c'est un
petit peu en fonction de la réalité
politique des différents pays européens
que cette réalité plus ou moins libéral
plus ou moins social peut s'affirmer
merci beaucoup françois poule et mathis
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste des institutions européennes
et merci à vous frédéric viale
spécialiste des questions européennes et
auteur de la gauche à l'épreuve de
l'union européenne aux éditions du
croquant